c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche que des émotions positives
les casquettes ça va m'aider chabot à
vous de suivre d'autres formes regardant
sa peine et ridha je souhaiterais d'arc
est surtout si ce sont tes potes ils
prennent compter les phones et qui
arrange les rendez-vous pour toi c'est
une affaire ça j'ai déjà fait pour des
potes à moi c'est très très bien alors à
titre personnel c'est une race sera
absolue mais c'est une rate rationnement
pour mes poils à moi j'ai pas de
problème avec les poils désormais
terrassera quand j'ai eu 13 ans et qu'on
m'a annoncé que je devais porter des
lunettes jusqu'à la fin de ma vie et
j'ai su transformer cette race radar cas
c'est ma philosophie et non barca j'ai
regardé hier soir la zone kiss in booth
là
à la boîte à bijoux d'asra c'est cedar
cas parce que je pense que ceux qui y
participent maintenant soit de
véritables professionnels et et savent
en tirer qui savent en tirer profit et
nous faire rire non pas l'heure des
temps mais avec eux mais c'est vrai que
ça véhicule pour certains programmes
l'achat de déchets en de la jeunesse 1c
les meufs qui veut d'équitation à quelle
race trafic alors pour moi c'est une
race rare vous l'aurez vous aurez tous
ceux constatés au travers mes
performances artistiques extrêmement
remarqué sur le plateau tv mp moi ce
serait mentir je faisais de la natation
du viet vo dao quand j'étais petit pas
de danse classique à revoir sur l'islam
[Musique]